[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et la rentrée de si on
parlait sport bienvenue dans ce premier
épisode de la saison 3 vous connaissez
le synopsis comme d'habitude nous
parlerons de l'actualité sportive du
département il y aura des analyses des
débats et des duels acharnés entre nos
experts pendant près d'une heure au
niveau du casting on ne change pas une
équipe qui gagne
nous avons harcelé pendant des semaines
pour qu'ils signent avec nous pour cette
saison aujourd'hui quatre chroniqueurs
ou devrais je dire quatre légendes sont
en plateau
je sais qu'il vous on a manqué
présentation en musique
on commence par l'un des pères
fondateurs de cette émission il est
notre spécialiste cyclisme et il a
remporté des médailles internationales
en cyclisme sur piste master's dans ce
tome qui n'hésite pas à dire ce qu'il
pense
le capitaine yann dujarrier du club de
vélizy 78 est avec nous pendant une
heure bonjour yann bonjour michael vous
êtes content de revenir sur cette
émission je voyais la rentrée est un
petit peu tardive mais mais on est très
heureux de revenir ça vous a manqué
ouais ouais bien sûr c'est trop trop
long comme comme toujours comme quand on
était à l'école on est bien content
qu'on aura les copains on passe de
l'autre côté à musicale et professeur de
pole dance à versailles ce sport très
physique qui mêle danse et acrobatie
autour d'une barre à la compil au coeur
des immuno à l'année dernière avec ses
analyses notre ambassadrice de charme la
sublime hélène de la branche est avec
nous aujourd'hui
bonjour élèves je ris beaucoup entre
sublimer entre e.on et des légendes
non mais moi j'aime bien j'aime on peut
continuer comme ça et me soucie encore
quand je vous ai proposé en tout cas de
revenir sur cette émission vous n'avez
pas hésité une seule seconde qu'un non
j'adore cette emphase de yann que vous
connaissez bien
on va voir dans l'émission emploi se
battre on verra ça repasse à ma droite
musique c'est un véritable scientifique
du sport il arrive à disséquer dans son
cerveau des milliers de séquences de jeu
malgré son emploi du temps surchargé il
est sorti de son laboratoire pour cette
émission
il est donc le professeur paul ws
anderson qui est avec nous également
pendant une heure
bonjour frédéric bonjour à tous alors
c'est un plaisir vraiment de vous
recevoir dans cette émission une
nouvelle fois sucré voilà donc vous êtes
vous êtes fan du coup de football
américain exactement mais est-ce que
vous avez d'autres disciplines que
couple d'agents tir est arrêté au chili
au dessus l'haltérophilie tofus gros
pour les petits bonhommes congo selon
l'invs qui s'arrange regardant pas
d'haltérophilie un parcours aujourd'hui
ne serait pas déçu
on termine par un mythe musique c'est
une véritable icône du rugby local il a
entonné plaisir pendant deux saisons
pour le conserver à cette saison nous
n'avons pas hésité à mettre son contrat
bénévoles ou clause de 222,1 millions
d'euros mesdames et messieurs le coach
genlis est de retour avec nous au
plateau après cette longue trêve
estivale bonjour jean vaujour michael
bons 222 millions d'euros soit à peu
près votre prix pour vous conservez
c'est pas mal on va parler de plaisir
notamment aujourd'hui jeu
suppose que vous continuez à suivre
votre ancien club oui bien sûr j'aurais
à tous les résultats règle générale et
principalement les résultats de
mezzanine club et maintenant vous êtes
coach en fédérale 3 non non le
randonneur à brisbane où servait que
gif-sur-yvette gif sur yvette
bon voilà on va continuer à en revoir
parlera quand même de de l'honneur avec
versailles notamment et je vois cette
saison alors avant de passer au
programme de l'émission j'aimerais qu'on
parle rapidement de cyclisme sur piste
et le club de wigan dujarrier le sait
vélizy 78 les masters ce dont vous
faites partie yann ont brillé la semaine
dernière sur le vélodrome de roubaix
pendant les championnats d'europe sur
piste les pistards sont repartis dans
leurs valises avec trois titres cinq
médailles d'argent et deux médailles de
bronze
yann vous avez notamment remporté la
médaille d'or sur l'épreuve de vitesse
individuel en devançant votre coéquipier
sébastien thierry lévy lisez ont
également conquis le titre en vitesse
par équipes dont vous faites partie
prochaine étape les championnats du
monde qui se tiendront à los angeles du
8 au 15 octobre
yann c'est une belle expérience ces
championnats d'europe
c'est un oui c'était une belle
expérience j'ai déjà et j'avais déjà eu
l'honneur d'être champion d'europe en
2012 ou 2013 monsieur exactement ça
c'est maintenant non non non non non on
est toujours content de monter sur ce
type de podium avec avec surtout quand
les le combat est rude et que devrait
être vers cité le surtout sur la vitesse
par équipes avec les anglais s'étaient
assez joué un dixième donc
donc ça c'est un vrai vrai plaisir avec
les copains d'obtenir ce titre ce titre
par équipes maintenant maintenant on
voit là pour nous c'était une étape
aujourd'hui on est dès le lendemain
voilà il n'y a qu'une seule chose qui
compte c'est celle titre de champion du
monde
on s'entraîne depuis depuis plusieurs
mois et même maintenant on peut même
parler d'année ensemble pour aller
chercher ce maillot arc en ciel chez
chez les vétérans et c'est quelque chose
qui nous tient à coeur et on on commence
à entrevoir puisque les performances
qu'on réalise en compétition son sens au
niveau de celle de celles qui ont permis
aux autres équipes d'être d'être
championne du monde les années
précédentes maintenant le niveau chez
les masters
évolue d'année en année les pas parce
qu'on s'est dit que les performances
baissent bien au contraire
donc il va falloir il va falloir encore
s'accrocher reste il ya encore deux
grosses semaines d'entraînement avant de
avant de partir pour los angeles et puis
et ben voilà on croise les doigts pour
pour essayer de ramener ce boom ayew qui
nous peut pas dire qu'ils échappent mais
qui est difficile d'aller à aller à
aller chercher voilà comment jugez vous
la performance de ian autour de cette
table gens vous avez un avis sur cette
performance et sur celle du club de
vélizy 78 également qui a réalisé je
rappelle trois types cinq médailles
d'argent et deux médailles de bronze ont
un avis sur de la formation comme titeuf
en europe c'est fabuleux
on n'est pas tous les jours je félicite
yann il doit être fantastique dans sa
discipline
oui c'est peut-être que deux ou trois à
concourir mais ça on le dit pas c'est
commencer à l'école des fans c'est
vraiment ces beaux d'europe
après je comprends son souhait d'aller
d'aller au bout et d'être champion du
monde parce qu'il ya pas mieux j'aime
perry monde c'est tout ce que je peux
lui souhaiter fabrique il ya un monde on
va dire entre les championnats d'europe
et les championnats du monde
forcément il ya un monde forcément un
panel de concurrents un peu plus un peu
plus large quoi après c'est ça reste une
grosse compétition c'est une compétition
continentale quand même et ça permet
aussi de se jauger bas à l'aube des
championnats du monde serait que les
compétitions sont assez proches donc ça
donne aussi dans la dans la préparation
ça donne une bonne idée de ce qu'on est
capable et si on est vraiment en ligne
avec nos objectifs et c'est très
encourageant pour a pour l'objectif
ultime qui est de remporter la couronne
mondiale
il ya une dernière question est ce que
vous êtes prêts pour le championnat du
monde est-ce que vous allez ramener
alors ici à dans les yvelines
j'espère
j'ai tout fait pour les chronos
les chronos sont sont là et
il faudra pas faire d'erreurs pour le
titre européen en vitesse par équipes
j'ai fait une grosse erreur qui ne nous
a pas coûté le titre mais qui aurait pu
coûter très cher puisque moi je perds je
perds trois dixièmes sur mon surnom
sûrement tour mais mais voilà on sait
qu'on a une marge de progression et
c'est vraiment sévère mon objectif à
titre c'est vraiment l'objectif pour
l'équipe maintenant à titre individuel
ben c'est pareil je fais je fais partie
des chais partie des prétendants au
titre
on verra faudra pas se tromper faudra
pas se rater ça ici sur ce plateau dans
un mois on va passer maintenant au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler des jo de 2024 et de la
victoire parisienne face à los angeles
le dossier le plus fort l'a t-il
emporter nous verrons ça dans quelques
instants nous allons également parler de
basket un agent yvelinois a réussi à
placer un joueur en nba
mais avant de développer ces thèmes
passionnants coup de projecteur sur le
club du rugby à de plaisir
[Musique]
pour son retour en fédérale 2 le
rugby-club de plaisir avec une partie
très compliqué contre bobigny ce
dimanche à 17 septembre les plaisirs
oies se sont inclinés sur leur pelouse
47 à 17 en encaissant un terrible 40 à 3
en première période on écoute les
réactions c'est une équipe qui a
beaucoup de plus d'expérience que nous
au niveau je rappelle que c'est en
fédérale 2 l'année dernière quand même
et c'est vrai que dès qu'on se consommer
un petit peu trop sur les phases de ruck
où six a raté un plaquage m'a tout de
suite ça faisait la différence ça jouer
dans le dos parce qu'on n'était pas
forcément capable de faire
collectivement on était on était pas mal
en place malheureusement
individuellement on a fait vraiment des
grosses fautes de défense
et puis bah face à une très belle équipe
comme ça avec les joueurs rapides qu'ils
avaient forcément on a pris beaucoup
d'essais donc là la mi-temps ça faisait
cher quand même jour miss vous 4
l'ancien coach de plaisir je suis obligé
de vous vous demandez ce que vous pensez
de cette contre-performance est première
contre performance de la saison pour
plaisir alors une cote aux performances
oui et non parce que comme
françois l'a dit capitaine c'est moby
est un club qui descend de fédérale une
donc c'est pas eu le marché qui avait
entre les deux équipes c'est deux donc
c'est pas vraiment le contre performance
cameron mystiquement il faut surtout pas
qu'ils qui pensent que voilà ça va être
bon ce sera dur de toute façon ce sera
dur ce domaine plus dans une poule qui
est assez compliquée avec des équipes
qui sont notamment très très bien armés
devant j'espère que sont conscients je
pense qu'ils en sont conscients mais
après je pense qu'il faut pas tout
remettre en question par rapport à cette
lourde défaite face à un club comme
bobigny qui encore une fois des 109 lra
lune et qui à mon avis l'ambition d'y
remonter immédiatement
voilà après après la saison va être
longue
être maître durant cette session si vous
êtes d'accord après la can personnes oui
sur cette défaite c'est une défaite
logique face à un gros club de fédérale
qui descendait de fédérale 1 c'est un
peu par rapport aux attentes c'est sûr
qu'une équipe de fédérale une on
s'attend à ce qu'elles aient un niveau
supérieur et un promu
après c'est vrai qu'une grosse défaite
comme ça faut sa basse et d'aisance et
riche en enseignements ça permet de
jauger où on en est par rapport au reste
du championnat
déjà par rapport à par rapport au plus
haut niveau si l'on l'espoir de vouloir
remonter après
ouais il faut faut rester je pense que
l'entraîneur a un projet de jeu et puis
faut qu' il reste fidèle à sa ligne est
pas tout tout balayer d'un revers de
main juste parce qu'ils ont pris ils ont
pris un résultat compliqué dès la
première journée
la saison est longue et a encore de
nombreux matchs à jouer dont qu'ils
auront le temps de s'améliorer et
progresser espérer de meilleurs
résultats à l'avenir
hélène ils ont tout de même montré un
autre visage au retour des vestiaires
ils ont marqué deux essais en 40 minutes
contre un essai pour bobigny finalement
il remporte la seconde période oui et de
toute façon ça peut laisser présager
justement d'autres oui après je perds
personne dans le père charre matches
joués et puis personne est mauvais il
voit là et les deux équipes sont bonnes
je pense que avoir un retour comme ça un
peu cuisant ça va mettre un peu le coup
de pied aux fesses pour là pour essayer
de faire quelque chose d'autre de
remonter et pas de se laisser là faut
surtout pas se décourager mais je pense
que là faut se dire ok ça a été
compliqué ça va l'être mais
il faut y aller même c'est le début il
ya toute l'année ok je vais mieux
maintenant et y aller plutôt que se
reposer sur des lauriers et puis tout
perdre en fin d'année yann vous voulez
réagir par barcella maintenant
simplement je pense que quand on quand
on monte de deux divisions comme une
commune au fait la saison dernière
pas de bol sur le tirage de taupe est le
favori de la poule qui descendent qui
descendent dès le premier match c'est
bon tirage mais bon voilà enfin c'est
pas de chance de tomber sur sur rodez
dès le départ
je pense que alors aujourd'hui il
devrait enfin s'il doit vraiment faire
un bilan il faudra le faire après les
matches aller et pas et pas tout de
suite sur les sur les deux trois quatre
premiers matches il faut se laisser un
peu de temps pour pour absorber la
différence de niveau et voir comment ils
peuvent
comment peuvent réagir en effet il n'ya
pas que du négatif dans ce match
puisqu'ils ont réussi à marquer des
essais je pense que c'était reparti avec
simplement des démarques de pénalités ou
des choses comme ça ce serait il ce
serait plus difficile à vivre là ils ont
peut-être quand même réussi à créer du
jeu même s'il nous fait seulement
deuxième période et ce qu'il veut
peut-être dire que bobigny a levé le
pied l'an sur la période
oui mais ils longue pesant une bobine a
peut-être ville pied sur le deuxième
période puisqu'il avait déjà une avance
conséquente il y a il faut il faut voir
faut voir le match il faut tout analyser
donc
avec simplement des gens qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on peut penser
mais voilà il faut il faut il faut
rester ils sont là encore pour apprendre
ou pour moi je pense que le bilan voilà
faudra le faire à la fin des dix ou
douze des deux des onze premiers matches
et puis voilà donc avec cette défaite
ils sont pour l'instant dernier
forcément au bout de la première journée
donc malgré cette défaite première
défaite de la saison plaisir espère tout
de même joué un rôle important dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 à cette saison
on écoute l'entraîneur de l'équipe
on verra comment ça se passera on se met
pas de barrières en tout cas on a une
philosophie de mettre un maximum de
volume de jeu en place donc voilà on
jouera en jour à 100% tous les coups et
on verra après par la suite si on peut
espérer autre chose c'est un gros
challenge évidemment un
surtout quand on voit la qualité de des
équipes de la poule
maintenant le
le groupe a connu une montée donc il a
comme une bonne dynamique
la question sur ce thème peuvent-ils
espérer se maintenir cette saison
oui ou non vous connaissez le principe
vous votez oui vous êtes partagés
yankees ont fait un petit duel entre
vous et l'aisne et jan heylen pourquoi
ils peuvent espérer se maintenir face il
ya eu des changements de d'entraîneur
des changements d'équipé enfin deux
membres de l'équipe
je pense que voilà si si il se repose
pas sur
enfin s'ils baissent pas les bras sur sa
défaite s'ils travaillent 6 6 voilà il
absorbe en fait tous ces changements il
n'y a pas de raison l'équipe je pense
que chaque joueur de l'équipe est bon et
je pense apple est selon vous oui moi je
pense il ya pour eux je me disais c'est
aujourd'hui c'est trop tôt pour pour
savoir on pourra déjà peut-être en
parler dans trois quatre matches et là
eh non ayant rencontré des adversaires
qui seront plus certainement plus à leur
portée et voir comment justement ils ont
réussi à part bondir par rapport à ce
premier match mais simplement à
encaisser le changement de le changement
de niveau mais pour moi aujourd'hui
c'est trop tôt pour savoir s'ils sont
capables de se maintenir au passe par
contre une chose est sûre c'est qu'on
leur souhaite
et là maintenant falloir attaquer les
bananes et les amendes pour comprendre
du volume parce que parce que je pense
que le gros la grosse différence entre
la 3 et la 2 c les un pote qui doit être
nettement plus plus importants et mais
bon maintenant leur objectif était de
monter l'année dernière ils l'ont fait
on va bible moi je dis quand on cherche
la merde on va pas se plaindre de
l'avoir trouvé ce sera déjà un best of
de 16 ans elle la jambe qui a raison qui
a tort
vous avez voté oui pour pour le maintien
de plaisir à la fin de la saison
alors j'ai voté oui pourquoi parce que
si on est pourtant classée 12 équipes en
jeu rappelle je vous dis oui parce que
si on n'est pas optimiste pour que le
club reste dans la division où il est
c'est mal parti
donc
mais ce sera très très dur moi pour moi
je connais un petit peu le rugby
pour moi il sait le calcul est simple
c'est qu'il faut y voir se battre avec
d'hautmont et arras pour se maintenir
donc après les autres équipes à mon avis
vont ils vont apprendre
ils vont apprendre dans le niveau et
apprendre le rugby et ils vont ils un
déplacement difficile dimanche à à
drancy
ils reçoivent bové dans la foulée ça
seul et y recevant au quatrième âge
d'hautmont à la maison je pense que
c'est le premier match qui pourront
commencer à approcher mais là ils vont y
vont ils vont essuyer pour moi une
défaite à drancy et peut-être encore une
lourde défaite à la maison contre bové
qui était un gros en gros morceaux de la
fédérale 2 mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
maintenant j'ai encore une fois oui pour
moi il faut jouer le maintien ce sera
très dur ce sera très difficile
voilà pourquoi ils ont deux clubs à
battre frédéric hélène le disais
précédemment
ils ont changé de coach cette année est
ce que c'était le bon timing pour
changer de coach en sachant que l'équipe
monte à meyrals introduire des
perturbations dans un système qui marche
c'est jamais forcément le meilleur
calcul après peut-être que la pression
un peu plus sur les coaches que les
joueurs parce que le groupe a peu changé
les entraîneurs récupère une équipe qui
gagne et et puis maintenant et se
retrouve dans un niveau au dessus et
c'est prenez pas vers l'inconnu quoi
après c'était un peu la bataille des
extrêmes c'est une équipe qui descend
conclu qu' monde dont six comme disait
qu'il suffit de on va voir un peu plus
clair dans l'est dans les deux trois
prochains matches voir déjà ce que fait
bobigny pour pourra juger le niveau par
rapport au reste
la poule etc et puis eux ce qu'ils font
aussi s'il arrive à progresser montré
des progrès marquer plus mais malgré les
défaites les défaites sont de plus en
plus rapprochées avec des écarts de plus
en plus serrés c'est toujours
encourageant pour la suite du
championnat qui est encore super genre
vous pensez que ça a déstabilisé groupe
je sais que c'est une question délicate
pour lui non mais bien sûr ce fait bien
sûr c'est délicat parce que c'est moi
qui suis qui suis concerné directement
moi ce que j'ai dit simplement c'est que
en enlevant le fait que ce soit moi qui
était l'entraîneur avec frédéric jardin
c'est qui est commun dit frais comme a
dit fred va être autre c'est vrai que
casser une dynamique je crois que
le groupe n'avait pas besoin de ça parce
que justement là
on tombe sur des équipes qui sont
expérimentés à ce niveau là avec des
gros pack et je pense qu'il aurait fallu
garder cette dynamique ça c'est certain
ensuite encore une fois la politique du
club ne m'appartient pas ils ont voulu
changer
à eux maintenant comme si bien dit notre
ami yann et b4 de recherche la merde on
la trouve au passé plein de l'avoir
proulx et on va fermer cette page
caroll alice alors maintenant vous allez
pouvoir être en roue libre
j'en lis pas ce qu'on va passer aux
thèmes suivants coup de projecteur à
présent sur les jeux olympiques 2024
le verdict est tombé aux alentours de 20
heures ce mercredi à 13 septembre la
ville de paris fortement pressenti
depuis cet été pour accueillir les jeux
olympiques c'est officiellement vu
attribué les jo de 2024 par le cio pour
fêter cette journée historique saint
quentin en yvelines avait programmé dans
le vélodrome national des activités
jusqu'à l'annoncent à 20 heures une fois
le verdict tombé la joie envahi la
structure on écoute la réaction de l'élu
aux sports jean car cela est une
réaction extraordinaire une réaction de
joie une réaction de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie on l'a senti lors de l' annonce est
maintenant l aventure commence
l'aventuré commence est une aventure
historique et ça va être passionnant de
vivre cette période
pour rappel saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillera le cyclisme sur piste au
vélodrome nationale le vtt sur la
colline d'elancourt le bmx sur l'île de
loisirs et le golf au golf national
dans le reste des yvelines à versailles
accueillera l'équitation et le
pentathlon moderne les épreuves de
cyclisme sur route devrait être organisé
dans la vallée de chevreuse quelle est
votre réaction quel a été votre réaction
ian après cette annonce vouziers ou
raconter je te plains championnat
d'europe donc et sincèrement
elle avait rien à battre puisque pour
moi la décision avait été déjà annoncée
avec l'alternance enfin par l'alternance
mais l'accord ne voyez pas de suspense
suspense avait rien donc
pas de pattes d'explosion de joueurs
rien de particulier vous savez voilà
depuis longtemps que 2024 ce serait pour
pour paris et tant mieux
maintenant wayne en mollema ma réaction
c'est que j'ai déjà mis une croix dans
mes vacances du mois d'août 2004 je sais
où je serai hélène vous quel a été votre
action pareille va lutter mitigeur un
peu après cette annonce mais pareil on
en avait parlé
à la fin de la saison dernière on savait
avec les 100 ans c'était forcément cette
année là et pas 2028
et puis au final ça changeait pas grand
chose que soit 2024 2028 pour les
sahraouis mais n'ont d'abord pas que
pour les 100 ans et elle est beaucoup de
structures qui étaient prêtes qui serait
boulette pour 2024 et qui n'étaient pas
produit 28 parce qu'elles ont réoccupé
donc à ne plus être libre
ensuite il y avait des problématiques
los angeles pour y faire les deux alors
que paris ne pouvait faire que de me
donne quatre jours miss je vois timoré
également sur sur cette question paris a
gagné puis c'est tout mais oui c'était
l'école des fans de toute façon on le
savait déjà
bon mais voilà c'était et vous prenez
2024 vous prendrez 2028 et puis et puis
voilà mais tant mieux tant mieux on aura
80 on les verra à vendre il aurait même
pu gagner gagner un peu de budget en
évitant de faire une cérémonie à lima et
cetera ça aurait pu voilà et faire des
économies pour tout le monde aussi bien
pour le seuil où tu pour les que pour
les pays organisateurs
voilà l'image et je pense que ça aurait
été compliqué d'accord mais bon c'était
voilà ça aurait pas dire c'est arrangé
mais voilà tout et tout était mis sur le
papier tout était tout était clair
maintenant bon à quelques milliers
d'euros près oui la question sur ce
thème le meilleur dossier l'at-il
emporté pour 2024
la question sur ce thème oui ou non je
suis pas voir si vous êtes chauvin ou
pas los angeles auraient pu être
également sur 2024 oui sont retirés
après celle en effet alors pourquoi il
le dossier de paris dont vous êtes tous
unanimes le dossier par exemple les
meilleurs ouvriers bon qu'elle aurait 15
% des 85 15 % gérance pourquoi je vois
je pense que c'est par le dossier qui a
fait la différence
je pense qu'il y en a dit très justement
autant los angeles pouvait faire les
deux que la france c'était plus sûr 2024
bien sûr il ya les centaines ça tombe
bien on va dire mais a surtout une
question de l'infrastructure et
peut-être aussi financier parce que deux
mille 2000 28,6 kamloops quand même très
très loin et on a parlé mais on n'a pas
la même mentalité que les américains
donc pour moi c'est pas le meilleur
dossier qui a gagné c'est une question
de meilleur dossier
il va falloir négocier il a gagné voilà
c'était bien comme ça et je pense à
arranger un petit peu tout le monde
surtout les français et los angeles
aussi puisque il avait des
infrastructures qui n'était pas prêtre
qui n'étaient pas prêtes et donc il
fallait monter ça leur laisse plus de
temps pour pouvoir les construire moins
dans l'urgence ils vont aussi bénéficier
d'un
dung est venu c'est au même et puis
d'une image c'est à dire que pendant au
lieu de pouvoir utiliser le label j o
que pendant sept ans ils vont pouvoir
l'utiliser pendant quatre de plus donc
pendant onze 11 années donc avec los
angeles 2028 et nous allons vous c'est
du business complètement complètement et
le maire de los angeles était était
particulièrement content de justement
d'avoir ces quatre années
supplémentaires pour pour pouvoir
à ramasser un peu plus d'argent encore
et augmenter le budget de fait quelques
millions d'euros dont vous disiez 90%
des infrastructures était construite si
on construit pour ça pour parler d'un
animal intervient alors que 80% des
infrastructures ont été construites pour
los angeles finalement ça arrange tout
le monde
si je comprends bien tu as fait et au
niveau des transports aussi ce que ça a
joué fredrik andersson c'était le gros
point noir vraiment pour los angeles en
2024 pour 2028 peut-être qu'ils auraient
un peu plus de temps pour construire des
transports du monde je suis pas sûr
qu'au niveau des transports c'est un
grand paris express qui devrait arriver
pour 2020 devient je pense que tu
aimerais bien moi je suis très content
que la france ait obtenu dossier et puis
surtout si ça permet d'entamer des
travaux et qui aurait dû être fait et
qu'on ne voulait pas faire parce que ça
coûtait trop cher
maintenant le fait qu'ils aient les jo
ça va un peu poussé les bas la main au
portefeuille quoi et puis après cette
histoire de nomination officielle cette
aide à politique politicienne et ils
sont arrangés pour que ça prend de moins
de risque possible parce qu'on a bien vu
me bats tous les esprits chagrins qui se
plaignent et vous allez voir ça va être
comme comme rio ça va être comme sotchi
où ça a mal fini
finalement après les jo le même matin ça
c'est aujourd'hui il reste plus grand
chose pour eux par contre l'on considère
qu'en cdd pays développés qui ont les
moyens et qui investissent dans ce port
qui sont nommés pour organiser même
tokyo ça va être pareil là ils sont sûr
de pas rater les jeux il y aura pas de
polémique comme a pu avoir pour les
autres et c'est sûr qu'on nous ment los
angeles et paribas 130 livres ils sont
tranquilles jusqu'en dalbade risque
voilà et puis surtout enfin donné 2
milliard d'euros aux américains ils
n'ont pas besoin de milliards d'euros et
2 milliards d'euros et ils triment et
les investir sur autre chose
sur tous les autres dossiers et de chez
eux à la limite si vous voulez faire si
vous voulez faire la promotion du sport
serait élu maire décision daba d'avoir
le courage de prendre des risques et
d'investir l'argent là bas plutôt que de
prendre des décisions déjà entendu plus
avec les sentences à tomber plus pareil
les deux milliards du cio ont traversé
énormément à la jeunesse sportive de la
californie vue
ça on n'en sait rien aujourd'hui alors
il ya également une grosse ferveur de la
part d'au plus de la population
parisienne hésité à 500 supporters ce
mercredi 13 s'étend au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour partager
ce moment on les écoute bah oui c'est
important ça fait longtemps que paris
attend les jo donc je pense que c'est
important de célébrer tous ensemble cet
événement aujourd'hui être présent
pour cette première échéance je dirais
de confirmation de gillot oui c'est
important on est acteur tous autant
qu'on est à chaque niveau donc oui j'en
lis vous pensez que le soutien populaire
de la part de la population française à
jouer dans ce dossier également ce n'est
pas forcément le cas aux états unis
au niveau de la viande nous pas une
grande ferveur alors qu'il n'y avait pas
de suspect oui bon d'accord c'est ça
parce qu'il y avait là et j'ai apprécié
mercredi après midi il y avait un coq
noir et l'histoire en fin d'après-midi
ce brave un cocktail ces vecteurs mentre
la proclamation des résultats il y avait
un coq thérèse mais c'est pour ça
c'était gratuit avec yann vous insistez
souvent sur la ferveur populaire autour
des événements oui parce que vous pensez
que ça a joué il ya quand même pas mal
de
personnes qui sont contre les jo en
france aussi un don qu'il n'ya pas
qu'eux
et pas que des gens comme moi qui sont
très très content de les accueillir bien
le contraire donc bon voila il en faut
pour tout le monde
en france on est aussi un pays on n'est
jamais content donc donc de toutes
façons ne faut pas qu'on peut pas
contenter tout le monde justement c'est
pas assez pas un c'est pas un gros
problème moi je de toute façon quand
quand les choses seront là tout se
passera bien et les gens seront contents
aussi maintenant et c'est un truc que je
me suis projeté c'est vrai que les jeux
enfin les fonctions quand même souvent
l'habitude au mois d'août bas de partir
en vacances et baillargues et beaucoup
beaucoup de français qui seront présents
sur les champs les événements moi
j'adore paris au mois d'août
il ya souvent personnes dans les rues
donc élancé d'éviter les embouteillages
pendant les jeux étaient bonnes choses
on va passer maintenant notre deuxième
coup de projecteur on continue à parler
des jo de 2024 mais maintenant au niveau
des sportifs cette victoire c'est
également leur victoire des centaines
d'athlètes se sont mobilisés pendant des
mois dans toute la france et notamment
dans les yvelines pour faire pencher la
balance du côté de la candidature
parisienne au vélodrome nationale il
était évidemment tous ravis après l
annonce officielle on les écoute au
micro de tv 78 pour moi c'est un peu
sans surprise parce que vraiment on a
mis toutes nos chances de notre côté
voilà c'était
beaucoup reggae sur les réseaux sociaux
et tout donc très contente
salses et ce en tant qu on les a pas
eues c'est taylor d'avoir on n'est pas
passé loin à londres on n'est pas passé
loin avant on appose présenté plusieurs
candidatures de temps en temps qui
étaient pas bonnes d'autres étaient
bonnes et puis à londres ça nous a fait
mal est lancé on a vraiment mis les
moyens et je pense que la candidature
était la plus belle et c'était normal
que paris et les jeux en 2024
un soulagement un soulagement et entre
dans l'ensemble de joie satisfait est
contente et plaisir vous êtes d'accord
gens vraiment là c'est la victoire des
sportifs à l'appartement oui bah oui
c'est fabuleux pour les sportifs pour
les sportives et aussi pour les
spectateurs et les jeux pour les jeunes
sportifs au là pour juger mais au niveau
déjà des sportifs qui ont reporté
du coup cette victoire qui ont participé
à ce dossier vous pensez ian troop de
soulagement et va être très important
même pour le monde 2
je me souviens que je me souviens de la
déception après
après l'annonce pour 2012 où on avait
vraiment on y croyait vraiment fort et
on s'était fait balader par par londres
même si c'était les voisins c'est ça
fait ça ça faisait mal et donc donc non
mais tant mieux et c'était de toute
façon fait que ce soit l'autre tour est
en effet beaucoup de beaucoup de
sportifs français et de deux grands noms
comme teddy riner com
on soutenu cette candidature est alors
tombé par mon style distingué voilà bien
sûr qu'il fait partie aussi du seuil où
nos sportifs français c'est vrai que
dégage une belle image
dans le monde et est du coup prennent ne
prennent de la place prennent de la
place donc du coup maintenant c'est ça
apporte sa porte une bonne visibilité
pour pour le sport français parce que
quand quand ils arrivent ils y restent
il reste présent les neuf titres de
teddy riner par exemple estanguet qui
avait dominé le cas de rick canoë kayak
dans le danseur
pendant pendant plusieurs années mme
olympiades et
leur renaud lavillénie qui est qui et
intéristes aujourd'hui qui voilà qui est
connue et reconnue dans le monde alors
que cette discipline est quand même une
discipline assez discrète dans le dans
l'athlétisme
ben voilà ce sont c'est tout c'est tous
ces sportifs qui font que ben on a pu
peut-être avoir avoir avoir ces jeux est
qui qui qui défendent cette candidature
et tant mieux alors sur le plan sportif
les jo-2020 4 se prépare dès à présent
cyclisme sur piste la nouvelle
génération des pistards tricolore est
symbolisé par deux jeunes pétris de
talent mathilde de gros 18 ans et
sébastien vigion 20 ans
malgré leur jeune âge ils ont déjà raflé
des médailles internationales ces
derniers mois pour eux les géo à paris
c'est un coup de boost
ouais bien sûr j'avais envie d être
c'est un peu on va dire l'objectif d'une
carrière mais ça serait way bella projet
de carrière de participer au championnat
un pic à paris pour l'instant je pense
plutôt court terme
c'est quand même dans huit ans donc non
j'ai pas encore imaginer ça mais tout
est bien tôt et n'a fait que trois ans
que je fais du vélo du coup voilà je
sais que voilà j'ai tout gagné chez les
juniors mais je sais que la marche
juniors élite est très très très très
grande était encore pour être médaillés
au jugé encore et man ont des progrès à
faire que ce soit physique technique
tactique la question sur ce thème les
jeux sont-ils un gros coup de boost pour
les sportifs du département
oui ou non je pense que vous allez être
unanime surveiller sur la question
pourquoi jean dieu d'abord par repas par
rapport à ce qu'on a vu qu'on vient de
voir les sportive plein d'avenir et puis
la petite mathilde groulx qui
d'après ian fera une médaille mathilde
fera pas une médaille au gie ou à paris
et fera déjà une matinée médailles aux
jo à pékin donc voilà donc alors je
passe bien sûr forcément il ya quand
même vivier d'aller dans les yvelines de
sportifs de haut niveau qui pourra pour
fermement représenter la france
frédéric ce qui a été intelligent je
trouve au niveau du projet le dossier
parisien
c'est qu'on a voulu incorporer ou
également les jeunes il ya eu la
génération 2024 qui a notamment été
symbolisée par mathilde gros justement
est également par victor lévesque est
originaire de rambouillet qui va
participer
sûrement aux épreuves d'équitation à
versailles voilà est-ce qu'on pensait
déjà à l'avenir dans le dossier parisien
quand on l'a monté forcément puisque si
on récupère les jus en 2024 c'est pas
pour les sportifs d'aujourd'hui c'est
d'en lancer dans cette célèbre que ceux
qui sont au top aujourd'hui peut-être
quelques-uns arriveront à se
maintenaient encore deux olympiades ça
fait quand même longue préparation et
tout peut arriver pendant cette perte de
temps mais c'est vrai que faut placer
ses billes sur les jeunes et c'est vrai
que ça va ça va pousser sur la formation
le développement de la formation des
jeunes sportifs et c2 d'alimenter le
vivait aussi de ba2 de sportifs
potentiel il ya des sports où où la
maturité ces 17 18 ans prend de la
gymnastique sont très très jeune c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui cccd jeune
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont 7 8 ans quoi et
qui vont se retrouver bas à paris et
puisque ce qui est très bien ce qu'est
ce qu'est ce qu'un peu magique c'est
aussi le bas toute l'histoire est déjà
tout le fait les 100 ans la france la
patrie des justes dans la pique etc
c'est vrai que ça fait une histoire
presque hollywoodienne on pourrait
presque en faire un film de ceux de
cette nomination que c'est pour ça qu'au
final je suis très content pour les pour
les sportifs surtout et puis même si
niveau politique on peut encore en
discuter sur l'organisation commencé
gérer pour les sportifs c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment le top et même pour le
sport en général en france c'est
vraiment ça va moins une très très bonne
chose
hélène au niveau des infrastructures
également on remarque tout a été fait
finalement dans les yvelines pour
pousser ces jeunes à continuer il ya le
vélodrome nationale pour mathilde de
grosses
c'est un juge et un outil de haut niveau
on peut le dire pour continuer à
progresser également la golfeuse
alexandra bonetti grand espoir de la
discipline qui vient de saint germain en
laye qui s'entraîne au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines
tout est fait vraiment pour les mettre
dans les meilleures conditions on peut
le dire oui et puis qui reste dans le
département et qui continue à
s'améliorer
c'est mais voilà c'est parfait pour vous
c'est là où là où il pratique ça va se
passer là où il pratique on vers
l'inconnu des infrastructures mais idéal
en conditions c'est ça va déjà comment
dire on va pouvoir aller dans des
performances qui continue à augmenter
des nouvelles personnes qui voient là
qui sont qui vont se motiver au fur et à
mesure de nouveaux
jeunes qui vont s'inscrit enfin le fait
dans les yvelines je pense qu'on va voir
toute une émergence de deux jeunes et de
d'espoir et talent là ça va être
fantastique je veux voir dans les années
qui arrivent je le ferai a également
peut-être aller préparer aussi
mentalement aussi ces jeunes a de grosse
pression parce que forcément le public
français va demander les médailles
oui ça c'est sûr mais ils ont encore un
avantage c'est de faire la compétition
sur le lieu sur lequel il s'entraîne et
ils auront leur point de repère c'est
très important de que ce soit
au cyclisme que ce soit au golf encore
mieux encore plus donc avoir le point de
les points de repère c'est un avantage
sur les autres sportifs étrangers et
avec le public derrière qui est on va
dire encore un petit peu plus
c'est sûr c'est une pression mais après
il faut il va falloir que ce soit une
pression positive pour les amener à se
surpasser
sportivement dernière question au delà
d'une pression c'est surtout une énorme
motivation dans le final stress positif
presque failli aussi ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les structures et
son dieu là pour s'entraîner dessus ils
ont pas attendre sept ans que le truc
soit construit pour pouvoir s'entraîner
dedans ils ont déjà tout le toit du
chalet suisse n'a pas forcément parce
que au-delà des repères c'est juste ils
ont tous les moyens à disposition pour
déjà de se développer correctement titre
d'exemple le vélodrome de rio où il n'a
même pas été livrées avant les jo donc
il a pas il a été livré pour les gens
plus compliqué on referme maintenant
cette large page jeux olympiques on
passe maintenant notre rubrique focus
sur le basket
on prend maintenant la direction des
parquets de nba dans ce talk l'agencé
l'an courtoise massport agency a vécu en
juillet dernier au barclays center de
brooklyn une nuit historique l'agent
olivier mazet a vu l'un de ses joueurs
sous contrat le basketteur frank et andy
keane à être sélectionné en huitième
position pour participer à la prochaine
saison américaine avec la mythique
franchise des new york knicks
le joueur de 18 ans qui évolue jusqu'à
présent sur les couleurs de strasbourg
devient le français drafté le plus haut
devant son futur coéquipier joakim noah
regarde cette séquence enregistrée par
son agent olivier mazet il est vrai
qu'il s'agit d'une draft vraiment
exceptionnel avec ce huitième choix qui
est tout de même le joueur le plus au
trafic est de l'histoire du basket
français franck unis qui n'a mais
surtout en direction des new york knicks
une franchise mythique et légendaire du
sport américain
donc c'est vrai que l'accumulation de
ces deux facteurs là avec cette draft
historique mais également cette
franchise
voilà tout à fait légendaire une
franchise qui a fait rêver tant de gens
aient une bille et qui aujourd'hui fait
partie des franchises les plus
attractives médiatiquement nous donne
quelque chose d'absolument incroyable
tant pour le joueur et sa famille on est
extrêmement content de la consécration
que ça peut ça peut avoir par rapport au
travail qui a pu mettre en oeuvre franck
mais également pour nous en tant
qu'agent car c'est quelque chose qui
valorise tout cet investissement on a pu
mettre en place ces deux dernières
années et il est vrai que c'est un
succès qu'on apprécie à sa juste valeur
et qui on l'espère en appelle d'autres
alors ce n'est pas la première fois que
l'entreprise élan courtoise massport
agency réussi à placer l'un de ses
joueurs en nba déjà l'année dernière
gershon yabou scellés avaient été
sélectionnés par les boston celtics en
16e position
un grand coup de chapeau en tout cas
cette agence est lent courtoise et
olivier mazet la question sur ce thème
le plus dur commence t-il pour olivier
mazet et sont franck ngyke ina oui vous
êtes unanimes sur la question pourquoi
dd le feu rapide à dégainer simplement
parce que
il comme quand on devient champion ou
qu'on est promu dans une dans une
division supérieure
ben
on le voit bien avec plaisir ben c'est
la suite qui est plus compliqué donc là
il va arriver par être donc pareil donc
dans une dans le top niveau du basket
mondial
la nba il va falloir muscler son jeu il
va falloir alors bien sûr qu'il doit
avoir les qualités parce que si nous ne
marquons pas pris mais bien il y a tout
eu tout un apprentissage certainement
les charges d'entraînement qui vont pas
être les mêmes que ce qui peut faire en
france fogué que les sportifs un mois en
france on est pas mal on a beaucoup de
mal avec l'entraînement on aime bien la
compétition mais l'entraînement beaucoup
moins
et ouais c'est dit parce que c'est
quelque chose que je pensais à beaucoup
de beaucoup de niveaux et donc beaucoup
de beaucoup de discipline
donc voilà peut-être une charge
d'entraînement qui va être plus plus
importante et qu'il va falloir
appréhender aussi des tactiques et puis
une rapidité jeu qui n'existe pas en
europe
la nba c'est bah c'est la dream team
donc bien il domine le basket le basket
mondial aussi bien chez les hommes que
chez les femmes
jean il va intégrer les new york knicks
la plus grosse franchise quasiment on
peut le dire en nba
pas forcément sportivement mais
médiatiquement qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous est-ce qu'il peut gérer
cette pression médiatique à 18 ans gérer
la pression médiatique
j e au point autre chose à faire qu'à
gérer cette affaire parce que là et
enfin l'or qui confiant et qu'il fasse
ses preuves
parce que là pour l'un et c'est tout
beau tout joli le plus dur reste à faire
c'est à dire confirmé sportivement est
certes il au prix certes mais il doit
avoir des qualités sinon ils vont pas
s'amuser à prendre des joueurs comme ça
mais après tout tout reste à faire et
affaire qui confirme et qui s'impose
dans le meilleur championnat mondial
donc c'est pas donné à tout le monde
c'est pour ça que c'est exceptionnel
on dit c'est le deuxième joueur qui
place et c'est deuxième meilleur havas a
faim contrat après noah bon d'accord
mais tout ça c'est beau c'est la
présentation c'est le cadeau mais après
l'intérêt tout le plus dur reste à faire
il va falloir qu'il faut l'or qui je
vais programme est très simple on a vu
un
un très beau transfert cette année enfin
on a un très bel été en transferts
football avec neymar et puis elle bat pm
ba paix il a 19 ans ou 20 ans 18 ans
voilà et mba pays c'est un joueur qui
est capable et qui s'est déjà joué là
utiliser le media première chose est qui
et qui en plus a quand même cette
intelligence et cette capacité est donc
l'âge ne s'est pas l'âge qui fait qui
peut créer un problème c'est il a la
maturité c'est toutes ces choses là qui
vont montrer qu'il est capable
et s'il est intégré à ces âges là c'est
qu'il est sait qu'il allait les passes
les possibilités l'encadrement fera
beaucoup aussi pour pour pour sa
progression donc si tout est
intelligemment ou et pour moi n'y a pas
de raison qu'ils échouent hélène
justement l'encadrement est ce que son
agent doit l'accompagner partout s qui
doit l'aider à s'acclimater à sa
nouvelle vie
oui je crois quand même à new york y
jouera au madison square garden je pense
que oui la vie est complètement
différente l'objectif sera différent le
niveau la façon de s'entraîner
ce qu'on demande aux joueurs qui sont
des stars là bas si c'est tout est
complètement différent donc ce qu'il
faut c'est qu'ils restent bien
concentrés en fait au final c'est ça pas
se laisser trop dispersée et gardez bien
le focus sur pourquoi il est là et
qu'est ce qu'il a envie de faire avec
anderson pour sa première saison il doit
apprendre où il doit tout de suite tenté
d'être titulaire il aura quand même dans
l'équipe des carmelo anthony des joakim
noah ou des lettons voilà comme porcine
ce qui qui qui est un gros joueur
également
est-ce que
voilà il doit chercher à être titulaire
tout de suite dans l'est dans les sports
américains surtout au football américain
nba quand on est drafté aussi haussé
pour jouer tout de suite je pense que si
l'on recruté numéro 5
c'est pour que c'est pour qu'ils
contribuent le plus tôt possible aux
succès de l'équipe et c'est sûrement que
l'équipe avait un besoin à ce poste là
donc c'est à lui aussi de faire ses
preuves comme on disait un des avantages
qu'il a c'est en étant en étant français
pas américain ce qui va arriver là bas
il a aucune connexion connais personne
pas il ya il peut pas être influencée
tellement négativement par par des
mauvaises amis ou des disques comme on
appelle des sangsues les gens qui
essaient de de grappiller un peu profité
de sa naïveté et je pense que encadré
d'olivier il aura aucun souci puisque le
succès joueurs aussi le succès de
l'agent donc l'agent a tout intérêt à ce
que son joueur
la progresse le plus vite possible après
il ya derrière il ya d'autres
engagements qui vont venir avec les
contrats publicitaires etc
c'est vrai que c'est des sommes
faramineuses et si on n'est pas bien
encadré ça peut vite monter à la tête et
et puis on l'a déjà dit à de nombreuses
reprises sur ce plateau il est jamais à
l'abri d'une blessure
regardez ce qui est arrivé à derrick
rose en janvier il a il a été anobli pi
et puis les gammes en croisé ligaments
croisés et aujourd'hui c'est plus
exactement comme joueur il a quand même
réussi à remonter mais mais ouais on
n'est jamais qu'une blessure d'avancé ça
fait pour ma transition derrick rose
était le meneur des new york knicks
il a été transféré cet été donc un
transfert qui les intéressent forcément
n 6 li na qui émeut l'heure de jeu il a
été transféré à cleveland pour jouer
avec lebron james
voilà tout simplement est ce que ce
transfert va aider frank andy keane à
s'imposer dans cette équipe je pense que
ça a été anticipé la part des nuire
d'une exclusion de toute façon si jamais
des mouvements qui sont faits au hasard
et je pense qu'ils étaient une fois une
fois qu'ils ont eue ils ont ils ont
adapté le joueur ils sont du bon on va
pourra laisser partir derrick rose s'est
pas c'est pas les mêmes exigences
salariales peut-être et puis l' avantage
aussi c'est que le français n'est pas
blessé il a il est en pleine forme et
alors que derrick rose bas
vivant qu'un genou quoi s'est il a fait
une bonne saison mais il a quand même
raté pas mal de matches à cause pas de
diverses blessures
et c'est vrai que ben jeunes par rapport
à un joueur plus anciens et c'est aussi
un facteur qui rentrent en jeu
et vu les quantités d'argent qui sont
mis en jeu bah ils sont très
généralement ils font attention à ce
qu'ils font c'est vous la cua je pense
que joachim doivent avoir un grand rôle
dans
ils sont 2 français du coup dans cette
équipe vous avez c'est à dire dans
l'intégration de ce jeune et aujourd'hui
on sait que joakim noah il a fait sa
place et il a il a fait ses preuves
donc ben il va peut lui servir de grand
frère pour pour s'intégrer pour pour
pouvoir enfin s'acclimater et puis
découvrir cette nouvelle vie tout
simplement donc
et alors là par contre ce qui va être
génial ça va être leur retour pour
l'équipe de france d'avoir deux joueurs
qui jouent ensemble au quotidien
ben pour l'équipe de france à peut-être
qu'une très bonne avec une très bonne
chose genre dernière question sur ce
thème est ce qu'il n'aurait pas dû
choisir une autre équipe plutôt que
enfin ils avaient le choix plus ou moins
de plusieurs équipes parce qu'il
n'aurait pas pu choisir une autre équipe
ou en tout cas tenté de choisir une
autre équipe comme rudy gobert l'avait
fait avec utah jazz dans un club un peu
plus moins médiatisés ou ou comme pierre
chaigne à bruxelles et qui est parti en
chine
histoire de s'aguerrir pour revenir plus
fort encore en nba à aux boston celtics
on n'aurait pas mieux fait d'être dans
une plus petite équipe
non non je vis pour moi s'il a vraiment
le talent pour se poser à ce niveau là
il faut pas il faut pas qu'ils hésitent
il ya 18 ans
il va faire ses armes au plus haut
niveau il va être encore plus fort donc
je vois pas l'intérêt d'aller plus bas
pour faire ses armes
ça c'est pour dire qu'on n'est pas pris
au jeu tout je suis à l'opposé les jouer
à barcelone ou à marseille
évidemment enfin ce sera le mot de la
fin sur cette crème on passe c'est
maintenant notre rubrique débats
[Musique]
notre débat concerne aujourd'hui le
tennis jusqu'à ce dimanche 24 septembre
le tennis-club de plaisir organise dans
son enceinte sportive le troisième plus
grand rendez-vous tennistique de l'île
de france derrière le tournoi de bercy
de roland garros
plus de 600 joueurs et 5000 spectateurs
sont attendus tout au long de la semaine
sur les courts de ce tournoi futures la
dotation globale du thon à s'élève à 25
mille dollars un montant qui attire des
têtes d'affiché françaises et
internationales
on écoute le président du club ché quoi
chez les futurs champions de demain
li tsonga les mahut et cetera les llodra
et compagnie sont passés par là donc
nous avons les futurs champions de
demain qui passe ici est donc je suis
ravi parce que les matches ne sont pas
de nature et ce sont des matches qui
sont à couteaux tirés et houleux le
tennis de haut niveau a rendez vous avec
le tennis soit de plaisir et ça ça me
fait plaisir
voilà il ya donc eu beaucoup de
champions mais le tournoi reste encore
anonyme
on peut le dire est ce que vous
connaissez vous par exemple avant de
venir à ça désolé mais pas du tout
campagne jean paraît très athlétique
qu'on a c'est que en france vous avez
roland garros
merci l'open enfin toutes ces choses à
fond que c'est difficile pour des
tournois annexes d'avoir une grosse
couverture médiatique et
à titre professionnel dans le vélo c'est
pareil à cause du tour de france il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont écrasés qui
sont écrasés sur sur la vie du cyclisme
le français et il ya la même
problématique dans le tennis avec la
côte de roland garros et des choses
comme ça donc la question sur ce thème
doit-on développer encore plus ce
tournoi ou doit-il rester ainsi parce
qu'on doit le développer encore plus en
sachant que c'est déjà un tournoi à 25
milles de là oui non est ce qu'il peut
arriver un jour à nîmes ou encore plus
haut niveau de la donation dotation des
joueurs ambitieux et déjà il ya déjà
tellement choses partagées
jean rhinois oui parce que développer
développer ça veut dire quoi développer
développer comme l'a dit yann il ya déjà
de deux tournois majeurs de vin et après
bon le président de plaisir qu'on a vu
c'est normal il fait la pub pour son
tournoi
bon après est ce que vraiment les sons
gars quand même qu'ils sont passés et
nous qui sont passées mais c'est normal
sont détournés donc les joueurs au
tennis il faut bien qu'ils fassent des
tournois dont qu'il fasse un peu partout
donc ça ça c'est ramener ramener
un exemple pour dire mon tournoi il ya
des grands joueurs qui sont passés
oui série surpasser dans beaucoup de
tournois
maintenant le développer c'est tout ce
que je peux lui souhaiter mais ça encore
une fois c'est quand même au niveau de
la lisibilité et il ya déjà deux
tournois majeurs donc là il ya beaucoup
de boulot quand même parce que même moi
qui étais pas l'un d'eux un entraîneur
de rugby plaisir je ne connaissais pas
du tout donc et c'est à côté c'est juste
à côté il ya le tournoi des petits as et
tous les mecs ont gagné ils sont parmi
les meilleurs mondiaux derrière ils sont
tous passés là bas c'était juste et donc
non après je pense que il ya de la place
pour tout le monde
pourquoi vouloir faire grossir illzach
ils ont une belle dotation hillary voir
de bons joueurs de bons futurs joueurs
et bien continuons comme ça ça leur
permettra ça leur permet pas de briller
sur interne national ou international
mais ils ont des bons joueurs ils ont
ils ont un beau tournoi 27 ans que ça
dure et voilà ça fait bien mais c'est
bien il faut que ça continue comme ça ça
sert à rien de vous verser roland garros
et voilà ça sert à rien de vouloir être
plus gros et au final peut-être de se
casser la gueule au niveau des points
atp également fredrik andersson ça
rapporte des points donc dans tous les
cas il y aura toujours des joueurs qui
viendront jouer à lui puis 25000 euros
ça mais quand même du beurre dans les
épinards cc non négligeable
je pense que l'intérêt principal de ce
tournoi là c'est d'attirer des joueurs
de qualité avec des joueurs de demain
pour que les jeunes aient l'occasion de
batteuses prise de contact avec le plus
haut niveau et qui voit encore la bac ce
qu'ils ont à travailler comment ils
peuvent progresser et je pense que celle
avons intérêt du tournoi c'est pas
forcément nécessaire d'augmenter les
dotations et d'avoir que des joueurs de
haut niveau sans que les joueurs du club
de plaisir puisse y prendre part
on va maintenant passer à notre la
dernière partie de cette émission on
ouvre notre page découverte un peu moins
d'un an après l'incroyable record de
robert marchand 105 ans sur la piste du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
un autre seniors va tenter de repousser
les limites du corps humain dans
l'enceinte sportive
jeannette augusto 82 ans originaire de
vesoul se lancera sur la piste pour
établir un record du monde de l'heure
féminin des plus de 80 ans la sportive
portera pour l'occasion le maillot de
leusse et vélizy 78 devant le public 47
ans après avoir réalisé pour le club le
record de france sur piste du 500 m
départ arrêté est forcément l'émotion
est présente jeannette était au micro de
tv 78 il faut pas trop en parler parce
que ça fait de l'émotion
ah ouais quand on a apporté déjà un type
club
et puis qu'on remet ça c'est quand même
quelque chose et puis certainement
tellement bien entouré c'est important
aussi
jeannette espère réaliser une moyenne de
28 km heure pendant son record pour cela
elle s'entraîne tous les deux jours en
réalisant des séances de 45 à 50 km
cebrian cette émotion pour le club des
vélivoles j'avais enfin oui je trouve
que j'en avais les larmes aux yeux je
vous vois qu'un truc c'est j'espère qu'à
80 ans j'aurai la même pêche qu'elle
parce qu'elle est
elle est rayonnante elle est pleine de
peps et
maintenant
ouais c'est le record des records de
longévité
on va venir juste après la question du
coût sur ce thème doit encourager ce
type de record oui ou non partager le
partager mme ryan antilles guyane gens
voient les genres quand c'est moi je dit
cui il faut les encourager et
l'étalement était tellement attachante à
faire sur mon vélo là le fait pas de mal
à personne
elle s'entraîne tous les deux jours toi
à 80 tu pourras pas te crois plus pédalé
donc que c'est pour ça que tu es jaloux
à la valse
voilà un déambulateur tu pourras pas non
et bien sûr pourquoi pas moi je dis que
c'est bien et c'est beau c'est voilà
cela fait notre histoire selon vous ça
me plaît ça venait il y avait là des
siens qu'il a fait l'an dernier robert
marshall c'est magnifique ce hacker mais
la problématique
enfin moi ce qui me fait mal c'est que
j'étais présent quand robert marchand il
a
il a il a fait son record c'est superbe
et quand je vois le nombre de personnes
qui avaient dans le vélodrome ce jour là
alors que quand on a des épreuves
européennes avec 1000 personnes mais il
y avait plus de monde que aux
championnats d'europe donc il ya un
moment où c'est quoi la terre c'est de
faire du vélo pendant une heure a pas
d'âge où c'est de pouvoir rouler à plus
de 70 km heure ou 60 km heure pendant
pendant plusieurs minutes et faire du
spectacle parce que peut-être un
problème de communication au sein de
votre fédération si ça j'en suis ça j'en
suis intimement convaincu on ne va pas
on va pas débattre sur le sujet parce
que sinon on va je vais me faire des
jeunes fâché fâché avec du monde mais
pas sur le plateau plutôt plutôt à
l'extérieur mais mais voilà donc c'est
c'est ça le moelleux des molles que le
gym et c'est il va encore y avoir plein
de monde dans ce vélodrome et puis ben
un peu de temps après on va organiser
quelque chose qui sera de l'ampleur
international voie aux raids de l'open
international il y aura personne et moi
je comprends pas donc mettez une
catégorie à master mettez le catégorie
senior super master super masters
plus de soixante dix arrestations chez
les championnats masters il n'y a pas
qu'eux y est ça va jusqu'à plus de 75
ans ont d'emblée loin que les ans il ya
des types de 50 quand on les voit sur un
vélo moi j'adore ce sont des vrais
cadets ce sont des gamins qui sont là et
qui se bagarrent comme s'il avait le
public à me voir les vieux peu d'aller
fabriquer ce qu'il n'ya bouquet du coach
sportif également
est ce qu'il appelle une question aussi
d'éthique aussi par rapport au fait de
voir des personnes âgées comme ça se
lancer dans des records petite question
des chick je pense qu avec les européens
cherchant à passer notamment plusieurs
tests médicaux avant de se lancer il ya
plus des gens formidables record de
santé publique parce qu on
on est bien en train de voir que c'est
par la performance en soi qui attire
cette puce le caractère exceptionnel du
participant et de la de l'entreprise
après on avait déjà discuté avec
monsieur marchand enfin reprendre
monsieur marchand avait fait son tour de
vélo
si les 6 s'il est bien encadré et si les
docteurs ont dit que la personnalité en
bonne santé et qu'il encadrer
correctement il y aura pas de souci
hélas ce qui est vraiment important sur
ce genre d'événement là c'est de montrer
aux personnes âgées que c'est important
qu'ils peuvent le faire et qu'il faut
qu'ils continuent de faire du sport
parce que de continuer à faire du vélo
le vélo c'est pas mauvais pour les airs
pour les pour les articulations
donc si vous avez des problèmes
d'arthrose et c'est peut-être que c'est
une activité que vous pouvez faire autre
que la natation ça vous permet
d'entretenir votre masse musculaire et
après on est sur des soucis de canton
perd sa masse musculaire on perd sa
force le risque dessus de jute augmente
et derrière il faut pas augmenter qu'une
chute le risque de fracture du col du
fémur est quand même assez élevé et le
problème de la fracture du col du fémur
sait qu'en moyenne dans les deux ans est
parti donc si on veut garder nous en
suis en bonne santé il faut les mettre
rapidement vous avez moi la seule chose
que voilà que je retiens entre ces deux
performances c'est vrai que quand ils
sont pas sur le vélo ce sont deux
personnes qui ont un peps et qui ont une
vraie énergie et donc c'est peut-être le
fait qu'yves quand tu te fais du sport
qui font kiffer qu'il garde cette
énergie sera tout cas de faire des
records à 80 ans yann jarrier c'est
presque la fin de cette émission mais
avant de se quitter une date à retenir
pour les amoureux de pole dance si je me
trompe pas et là ça vous concerne
oui ce week-end
donc ya tout juste regarder un petit et
que je fais juste avant il ya un jeu
fait de marc allégret je fais de vos
seins sur le produit
[Musique]
hélène hélène cet événement c'est ce
dimanche 27 ans voilà donc là c'est le
pôle art une compétition professionnelle
offerts une compétition artistique
vraiment que c'est sur l'artistique et
des personnalités des différents styles
de paul après il ya plusieurs
compétitions possibles via le pôle sport
qui est plutôt en début septembre
on a une autre compétition en octobre
qui mêle le sport et l'artistique aussi
nous lie à plusieurs compétitions
mais on a cru comprendre un jour miss
vous y serez à cette compétition
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouvent le jeudi 5 octobre un nouveau
à 6 ans par les sports on va terminer
par une citation de pierre de coubertin
le sport va chercher la peur pour la
dominer la fatigue pour en triompher la
difficulté pour la vaincre
je sais que vous adorez ce type de
situation après l'émission
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]